dans les années 90 plusieurs détaillants
québécois dominer le marché
le shadow jacob dans un jardin étaient
des destinations incontournables pour
plusieurs consommateurs et
consommatrices 25 ans plus tard le
paysage a grandement changé au canada
notamment ya de plus en plus de
concurrents américains et européens qui
ont débarqué alors que le marché restait
stable
l'arrivée de concurrents étrangers
l'explosion du commerce en ligne change
la donne
alors que certaines bannières comme
jacob ont frôlé la faillite
d'autres comme dans un jardin
entreprennent une métamorphose pour
ramener la marque au goût du jour
keith allait l'amener à se rajeunir et
c'est ce qu'on va faire c'est ça le un
des grands défis en fait de cette marque
avait toujours énormément de couleurs
les produits étaient probablement
différent là aujourd'hui on s'en va pas
dans ce sens donc il va avoir déclenché
dans un vin le noir et le blanc
en poste depuis un an le nouveau patron
de la chaîne s'est donné pour mission de
retrouver dès 2015 la voie de la
rentabilité
le défi vraiment c'est en fait d'un et
nos clientes à nous suivre et aussi de
convaincre les non clientes à rentrer
chez nous pas se dire ah ok dans un
jardin c'est différent c'est nouveau que
ce qui se passe je veux voir
en plus de se refaire une image la
chaîne veut gagner des parts de marché
au canada anglais le canada anglais
c'est un marché qu'on n'a pas été
capable de percer depuis des années on
essaie on essaie je vous donne un
exemple c'est notre gamme pas trente
heures baby croise deux center bébé dort
dîne impossible pour un anglais fan de
prononcer sa maison sur un nom
anglophone sur des symboles biais
canadien on pense pouvoir plaire au
reste du canada mais une image rafraîchi
des produits mieux ciblés ne suffisent
pas dit cet expert en magasin de n'avoir
que des produits et un beau sourire
ce n'est plus suffisant vous devez être
partout votre consommateur veut vous
voir
c'est à dire en magasin sur une tablette
sur un mobile
en plus d'investir dans un nouveau site
web dans un jardin tentent d'interpeller
directement des consommatrices qui
s'appelle glace et ça fait mal c'est mon
parfum pour hommes préférés championnat
pour faire connaître les produits
la chaîne fait appel à des influenceurs
du web de riou dans le monde des
cosmétiques il s'agit surtout de jeunes
femmes leur chronique sur youtube sont
suivis en moyenne par environ dix mille
abonnés contrairement à la publicité
traditionnelle cette forme de marketing
est beaucoup plus ciblées dans l'ère
numérique mais aussi au goût du jour
parce que les clientes sont partout
maintenant ici vincent maisonneuve radio
canada montréal